>> Hi, my name is
Anande and I'll talking
about Resource Central.
We are exploring ways to create
intelligent and efficient
cloud platforms.
To do this, we want
to leverage machine
learning into the cloud platform
resource management.
There are several research
challenges like,
how can we make this machine
learning integration
generic enough?
So, the idea is to put
Resource Central right
into the center of Azure.
As you see here, various
resource management services in
the cloud platform conduct
Resource Central and get
predictions about
the future behaviors.
So, Resource Central is
a general platform for
collecting telemetry,
learning about
the prior behaviors of
VMs and servers and
when requested,
it can produce predictions
of the future behavior.
We have some highlights here.
We had a paper in
SOSP17 about this.
The Resource Central service
is currently in
production in Azure
compute fabric.
Here, we can see the architecture
of Resource Central,
there are two main parts of it.
There is offline processing
where you collect telemetry,
you create machine-learning
generated models,
and there is an online
serving platform which allows
the resource managers
to make queries
to Resource Central
and serve predictions.
As you can see, with
Resource Central,
we can predict with
a high quality various
metrics of workloads.
That is a strong reason
to integrate
machine-learning in resource
management in platforms.
Here we have some future machine
learning challenges that
we are trying to address,
for example, online learning
and doing the said skill.
Now we have a small demo
here which shows
the VM scheduling in Azure
using Resource Central and
without using Resource Central.
So as you can see here,
without using Resource Central,
there will be a high probability
of rejections of
workloads because of
the fixed capacity of the VMs.
With Resource Central, you get
informed knowledge about what is
the kind of work load and
the nature of that workload.
With that information, you can
achieve all subscription with
the same capacity and without
exhausting the resources
several number of times.
So, in this approach
without Resource Central,
you can see there are
a high number of rejections,
whereas with Resource Central,
the rejections are low
and also that we are
remaining within the capacity
of this all. Thank you.